well Mari and Yuta thank you so much for
joining me today it's a pleasure thank
you for having me
Oh Mari I'd like to have you start out
by telling me just a little a bit about
this whole overture with the arts thing
that you're involved with with your
sister as well yeah so my twin sister a
kilonewtons starting this organization
overture with the arts with a goal to
bring performing arts training to
underprivileged youth and it's sort of
expand at first to starting off
underprivileged used in the montreal
area and its expanded and now we do
stuff all across Canada but it's it's
her organization and I this was the
third year in a row that I've been
performing for her Black History Month
events but it's the seventh year in a
row that overture with the Arts has been
bringing black history education through
the arts to schools much roll-over true
with the arts is not specifically a
black thing though right no no it's not
arts it's it's the arts yeah they in
fact they have presentations that go on
for Holocaust Remembrance Week they have
stuff going on for Black History Month
it's just this particular performance is
for Black History Month because it's
read word how did you get involved with
this in the Black History aspect of it
mm-hmm well I've long I've always been
an artist and I've been a professional
artist since I was seventeen and for me
art and activism and social justice have
always been intertwined my heroes are
people like Chuck D you know Public
Enemy I was very influenced by Rage
Against the Machine so I've always had
this interest and because my my twin
sisters organization has been doing
similar work it was just sort of like
this natural progression that we started
working together she's really good at
the the strategic elements of like
booking shows and logistics and I can
perform and write so she's like my agent
in a way although I won't tell her I
won't tell her that yeah yeah so much
what about this this particular show
this year slam obsidian what is that no
slam obsidian is a presentation that
combines elements of slam poetry and the
way I do slam poetry it's almost like
acapella hip-hop verses there's some
video elements to it it's very
interactive with the audiences where
I'll ask questions and there's even a
poem there's a couple poems actually
that I have students take part in to
help me tell those stories and this year
we decided we won the emphasis to be on
prominent figures in black Canadian
history cuz and actually this was this
started cuz I got called out my students
couple years ago and I was talking about
kind of usual suspects your Malcolm X
Martin Luther King and they're like well
what about suppose apart Rosa Parks of
course and they asked what about some
Canadians and I was like you know what
you're right there's some amazing people
here did you know about the Canadians in
any detail before you started this you
know what I'm not even gonna lie
not nearly as much as I do now as much
as I should have I was guilty of the
same thing that a lot of students are in
that so much of our media comes from the
US and it just sort of passively you
know consumed these stories about
amazing people but I didn't know nearly
as much about Canadian people as I
should so tell me a little bit about who
you're featuring that in slam Obsidian
him and why you chose those people sure
yeah well one person that we talked
about is viola Desmond and of course for
those listening who may not know she is
she's had quite a bit of acclaim
recently in Canada but viola Desmond
staged a similar similar to that six or
stage the protests similar to that of
Rosa Parks before Rosa Parks in years
before about ten years before and that's
something that I didn't know right so
she sat in a movie theater in New
Glasgow Nova Scotia turned out the movie
theater was segregated she refused to
give up her seat and it ended up you
know although she ended up losing her
case she inspired another woman named
Carrie best so we also talked about now
interesting note Kerry best five years
before Viola Desmond actually took the
same stand in a stay in the same theater
in New Glasgow with her son right now
Kerry best was so inspired by the
discrimination she faced in that theatre
she started the Clarion which is one of
one of her Halifax's first black
newspapers so she started the Clarion
and one of her first major stories she
reported on this incident that happened
to while the Desmond and they try to
impart this on my on the students I
talked to you that acts of resistance
and social justice don't exist in a
vacuum so you might take a stand and you
might not personally see the benefits of
taking a stand but collectively if we
all work towards changing things
eventually change does happen now you
you use slam poetry just explain perhaps
for those who aren't aware of that
exactly what that involves and how that
works sure so to me slam poetry is
poetry that is meant to be performed
live so it's poetry with when you're
writing it the intent is that it'll be
performed rather that rather than just
read by people so to me it's a hybrid of
theater of poetry because some of the
you know standard tropes are metaphor
and simile and all that stuff exists
still but it's almost like a monologue
you're giving with the intention of
doing it for a live audience and there's
a real beat the way I do it yeah I was a
hip hop artist and an emcee before I was
an actor some people who might you know
very much real in the late 90s I was
part of a collective called Kobayashi it
was a nasty jazz group and I was the
emcee in that group so I started off
rapping and then got into poetry through
my love of hip-hop music and now really
my mic slam poetry is just like acapella
hip-hop Omari Newton I have to ask you
to give us a little taste of that I can
give you a taste so this is a signature
piece of mine that I perform around
Black History Month and it's called
doodoo brown it goes like this
when I was a young lad playing in the
sandbox a boy said and word your skin is
doodoo brown so I got mad pissed and
cocked my fist to deliver a crushing
pound when suddenly from above me I
heard this frightening sound it was my
mother on the balcony saying boy put
your fist down sheepishly I agreed and
balled my fists and lowered my head my
mom said why come home right now I'll
make your backside red embarrassed and
scared I said a prayer and hope no one
was looking
bit my lip let a final threat slip and
headed for my whoopin now my dad said
boy you can't punch white people right
out in the open when the police come
you'll be the one they cuff that ain't
no joke and explain to mom and dad what
that boy said to make you vex and when
you explain things to West Indian
parents a beating is always next I said
mommy he called me the n-word said my
skin was doodoo brown acting like this
was no place for me and I should leave
this town my mother touched my little
head my father said son listen you can't
use violence every time someone is
distant than my folks they spoke in
unison and this is what they said they
said your skin is brown like Ellis sound
like Jordans roundball head like mango
trees and fallen leaves and freshly
baked sweetbread Foundation beams the
earth the breathes and dried coconuts in
the West Brown is the color of Muhammad
Ali's chest
Maya Angelou's text and mother
cuz breasts that boy is just confused
you have to set him right now my parents
held me in their arm till I fell asleep
that night so the very next day I went
out to play and there was that same boys
smiling he figured I caught a beating I
was ready to keep on wiling so this same
racist young man destined for the Klan
said n-word your skin is doodoo brown so
I looked at him and just shook my head
and smack that smile into a frown now my
mom and dad were right that night but
you must remember this though my palms
are white when I fight Brown is the
color of my fists Oh beautiful thank you
I'm alright since you've been doing this
with your sister performing for these
things what has Black History Month come
to mean for you Black History Month to
me really is just its history right we
call it Black History because we're
emphasizing specifically the
contributions of African Canadians but
to me it's such a pivotal part of North
American history and to me it symbolizes
a sense of pride and my culture and
people came before me and it symbolizes
hope for the next generation coming up
because I feel like they're already much
more evolved than even my generation I
was at an audience today I was talking
to the study and I looked out in the
audience and the studies of school in
West Mountain right and I looked down in
the audience and I saw it was a very
diverse audience I saw people who look
like they were you know quote-unquote
black and quote-unquote white and
quote-unquote Arab all sitting next to
each other learning together and it was
it was really really inspiring because I
remember I was the only black kid in my
grade basically you know my sisters and
I were the only black people in our
school and I feel like just having a
chance to go back and speak to this
young generation about the past so they
don't repeat the same mistakes going
forward
Omari Newton thank you so much for
coming in it's my pleasure thank you for
having me